[Music]
that's what it looks like when a legend
is on the screen that's legendary
cellist yo-yo ma paying a please playing
rather piece by the great Johann
Sebastian Bach ma shared this video on
Twitter as a tribute to the health care
workers on the front lines he says their
dedicated service gives him hope now
this is a second video that ma shared of
himself playing what he calls songs of
comfort as a corona virus spread that's
so nice he's not the only one using
music to brighten people's lives vitomir
duthiers joins us again from his New
York apartment to play the guitar for us
[Laughter]
good to see you once again so listen
guys Turan and Calliope e10 are 9 and 6
years old and just like yo-yo ma they
also play the cello their instructor
tasked them with holding virtual
concerts during this period of social
distancing but after their mom Rebecca
checked in on a self quarantine neighbor
she made other plans
dressed in concert clothes then aided by
mom Rebecca siblings collie Opie and
Tehran ten are here to perform for their
self-quarantine neighbor
78 year old Elena swamp I haven't been
out of the house well except in the yard
for the last five days
Elena lives alone and says she got a
call from Rebekah asking if she needed
groceries when Elena said she was fine
Rebekah thought of a different author
Helen I really loves music
so I asked her she'd like if the kids
came to the porch she knows that I love
music and I really like her kids they
are terrific
so Halina joined the kids outside
practicing responsible social distancing
of course we loved playing the cello for
other people and then we thought about
how she was stuck in her house so we
thought it was a great idea and it might
make her happy
if you let Elena tell it happy would be
an understatement well I was just I sort
of feel like a little kid
[Music]
that was such a beautiful song guys it's
summer the wind by Suzuki cello book
number one not only was Galina moved by
Turan and Calliope is playing
she also said it was reassuring that
Rebecca checked in on her in the first
place and guys that is an important
reminder for all of us that small
gestures can make a big impact and how
important it is to look out for our
neighbors and our friends and family I
love everything about that story Vlad
everything about it it's really just
great thanks Vlad